una nueva mercancía en alta demanda las
redes sociales de bolivia están llenas
de anuncios de búsqueda y oferta de
plasma hiper inmune es decir el plasma
de recuperados del cob y 19 hay quienes
piden hasta 1500 dólares por someterse a
una extracción de 600 mililitros el
comercio está prohibido pero las
autoridades no pueden evitarlo el
diputado boliviano amílcar barral estuvo
cerca de morir por causa del coronavirus
obtuvo una donación de plasma pero no
fue suficiente y tuvo que pagar 600
dólares por un segundo tratamiento
mi hermano logró encontrar a un donante
por así decirlo
vendieron a cuatro mil bolivianos
con este plasma más logró reforzar más
mi
la dejé en las defensas en mi cuerpo y
demás y comenzó las operaciones
el diputado propuso una ley para que una
persona curada en hospitales del estado
se comprometa a donar plasma pero el
parlamento optó por fomentar la
solidaridad aunque hay miles de
recuperados el principal hemocentro de
la paz no ha recibido muchas donaciones
siempre nos hemos ido más por el lado
solidario por el lado altruista de las
personas no de que puedan realmente ser
voluntarios y poder donar de manera
voluntaria por amor al proceso
lamentablemente en nuestro país no se ve
tal amor
janet que prefiere mantener su nombre
completo en reserva perdió a su padre
por falta de plasma ahora ella quiere
ayudar a una persona en concreto
haciendo una donación yo pase lo mismo y
no me ayudaron y las personas que
quisieron quisieron lucrar con el plasma
y era demasiado mucha cantidad y hay
personas desesperadas que no pueden
conseguir les estafa no les asaltan la
transfusión de plasma sanguíneo ha
salvado muchas vidas pero es aún un
tratamiento experimental probado en los
más grandes hospitales del mundo